our next speaker
he's a bit of a nomad he's lived all
over the the country possibly the world
um he did spend a lot of time in chicago
which apparently ruined him a little bit
you know you know what they say about
economists that come out of university
of chicago they have a reputation for
having really bad taste in what they
think is pizza
he doesn't realize how bad that slop is
and i'm gonna i'll call it's a good
casserole but some people say it's an
insult to casserole but he doesn't know
any better he hasn't spent enough time
in the northeast where the pizza belt is
he's also an economist right do we
really trust any economist they always
have on the one hand and the other hand
they use data this economist doesn't use
data at least anymore he uses r that's
how we know him
uh
so a lot of things wrong with him but a
lot of things right with him please
welcome jonathan to the stage uh welcome
i'm really happy to be here um i really
miss seeing uh all of you in person and
but i'm really happy to be here
uh i i really love seeing what happens
to our language like i think this is
just such a great community i'm i'm i'm
happy to be a part of this um
i will talk about explainable machine
learning um
and
uh explainable machine learning is like
a really hot buzzword now and and
hopefully we can
bound this in some amount of
reasonableness
um
so
i i think one of the cool things that we
do here is we actually have a field
experiment and explainable machine
learning to see how people actually use
this and uh working with experimental
data um
i uh used i started
looking for looking forward using all of
the new bayes tools so a subtitle this
could be how i learned to stop worrying
and love the bays with rstan arm
another subtitle could be dang it jared
is always right because
it turns out that what jared told me to
do was the right way forward
this is joint work with selena carter
who's a phd student at carnegie mellon
university she gave a really great talk
on the first half of this
um at dcr so if you're curious about
that
um you know please click that link this
is really a sequel um so too fast to
machine learning tokyo model drift um
selena talked about building the machine
learning model and i will talk about um
all the other things we did in order to
implement that machine learning model
and and and to figure out if explainable
machine learning actually improved
anything
all right
so so why do we care about explainable
ai and i think one of the big reasons
for this is just that
as ai takes on more consequential
decisions
um we might need humans in order to do
that type of validation
there have been
a lot of prominent examples and i have
to commend people as uh journalists who
have looked into these examples
where
we trusted an ai to make consequences
consequential decisions and
the ai made an error and that error
impacted someone's life quite severely
there's an example of
an inmate so
many states now use ai models in order
to
learn about when somebody should be uh
released from prison
uh one of those models because of uh
data inputting error uh kept somebody in
jail for much longer than they should
have and only from that inmate comparing
uh like physical examples with another
with another inmate did he realize like
what was going on
uh there's other examples in health care
setting so
there was a hospital that used a model
in order to figure out how to triage
different patients
um
and it it was discovered that that model
was heavily racially biased wasn't
because race was used as a predictor
within the model but it was because
um
because revenue was used in the model
and revenue
expected revenue from a patient tends to
be highly correlated with race um
so we need our models to be able to
tell us why they're making decisions
because maybe we need humans to validate
this
you know another reason is that
models are just black boxes and
so we need these models to explain to us
uh why they're making their decisions
but another reason is just that well
explaining the model can help us make
better models so as data scientists you
know we want to build the best model
that we can and often within the model
building process if we can have
explainable components of this then that
helps us make better models okay
so explainable ai uh is important for
consequential decisions let's look at
the context that we're doing is here so
we partner with a major development bank
who asked us to predict whether
sovereign guaranteed investment loans
would be delayed so these are like
big infrastructure loans that are
millions of dollars
and um
a lot of these are delayed for reasons
that you can imagine why a big
infrastructure project would be delayed
and so an example of one of those
projects is
the modernization of the salto grande by
nation hydropower complex and this is a
uh
so this is a dam that's on the border
between argentine argentina and uruguay
and uh you know this was an 80 million
dollar project um
these are the types of
predictions that we're looking to uh
we're looking to make whether a project
that this is going to be delayed so it's
a certainly consequential decision
and if we can uh you know get the model
to explain to us why it made the
decision maybe people will understand it
more and trust it more
in terms of what explainable ai exists
there's um you can kind of
break this down into
explainable ai that looks at global
feature importance and marginal effects
so these are things like partial
dependence plots that do are essentially
numerical derivative methods that look
at how the predictions change around the
values of certain variables global
feature importance
looks at well what if we exclude this
variable from the model how much does
the uh
the model fit change
um on the other side of things there's
explaining individual predictions so
lime and sharply values are really
popular and there's there's very good
implementation for this this stuff in r
so
there's a daleks package fast chat
package pdp and line packages
um and you know just to be just to
channel a little bit of gelman right
here
you know um another solution to this
maybe is just not to use such
complicated models so why are you
estimating a thousand decision trees
when maybe a single decision tree that
has
restrictions on the the complicated
neces of its um
decisions you know if you can fit a
model on into a paragraph like maybe you
should use that if the performance is is
no worse than a very complicated model
um so there's you know if you're if
you're curious um
you know i think if i had to do this
again i would probably do something that
was just a much more simple model that
was still built using machine learning
but just restricted in terms of doing
very simple things and um
if you're curious there's a really nice
uh package uh called corals that
restricts to these very simple decisions
um
so so and you know no surprise andrew
gillum was right
um
really nice dashboards that's kind of
how things are trending towards
there's this uh shackash uh dashboard
that is in python that presents all of
these
uh explainable ai things all at once so
you get your local explanations you get
your future importance
you can drill down by different
observations
google the google what-if tool is really
popular as well
it's nice because it allows you it does
all those things but allows you to
figure out another data point that's
really similar except varies in that one
that one variable that you
you know want to see the the the counter
factual
um so those are the tools that exist i i
don't know of a of a comparable
dashboard with an r that uh so if people
know this i know i'd love to hear from
them
um
we were restricted to using tableau
because the institution we were working
with really wanted us to implement it in
tableau so we just built a series of
tablet dashboards ourselves
um
all right so let's talk about the the
implementation in the survey that we're
going to run in order to understand the
impact of explainable ai
uh the organization we worked with was
very kind and let us
do a survey for 685 685 team members
we ran this from may to june and we got
a very good response rate we had a
control group that we gave just the
predictions and the confidence intervals
for those so we presented them with okay
here's your project here's what we think
the new here's the model says that it's
going to be delayed we also provided
confidence intervals around that which
we think was really important um this is
not like a real control group because
they're still getting the predictions
but we were worried about issues of
power and also the organization you know
they they wanted us to promote this
model so they they didn't want us to
give a you know one control group that
didn't get any predictions
the explainable treatment
they got two extra screens so what they
saw were information on model
performance so we gave them uh predicted
true plots as well as some
just statistics about the model
we also gave them model explanations in
terms of
uh these charts that describe exactly
for a particular project what what
contributes to the prediction of uh so
the and so these are uh really nice
shapley plots
um and we embedded these within a tablet
dashboard
the
the general structure of the experiment
was we you know surveyed a a manager
about what they expected the delay to be
then we show them these these different
screens
and then we looked at
whether they updated their uh their
prediction guess
we focused on four different outcomes
but the first one was whether they
self-report that the machine learning
tool is useful
um the second one was whether they
understood the machine learning tool and
then we looked at whether they actually
changed the delay estimate before and
after viewing the tool
and then we looked at the absolute value
of that change in delay estimate
there were five moderators that we
thought might have an impact uh you know
one was definitely the explainable
treatment
their role like whether they're senior
or junior the total amount of the loan
um and then they're like self-reported
machine learning familiarity
all right so
you know from here to analyze the data
we have three different types of
variables order logistic poisson
logistic
um and and this is you know this is this
is gonna take we don't have so many
observations here um and i was
immediately worried about
ending up on andrew gilman's blog as
as like why did you pee hack his results
um
and so
you know i
you know like like like anyone here i
think that my first resource was good it
was to go to twitter so i asked out i
said you know what are some good our
stats packages uh for doing this types
of you know in particular order ordinal
model multinomial regressions are not
something that i had used in a while
um
and our fearless leader said you know in
in so many short words one word in fact
he just said r stan arm and then for
some reason put a uh an asterisk there i
mean
what a jedi master
um
i have to give a uh
a consolation prize to my other friends
grant mcdermott and jim savage who
replied gave me some great advice
um one of my friends just said just do a
linear model um thank you jesse jesse's
a professor at brown thanks for that uh
but jared's really jared jared's right i
mean it turns out that
jared was uh led me in the right way um
and uh but you know i i sort of knew
that was the right way and i i want to
dig into this bayesian cringe that
andrew gilman talked about so why was i
resistant for going bays
i think a big reason for this was the
idea that well i'm writing a research
paper i'm going to set it to a journal
i'm already doing machine learning stuff
like
you know the referees how are they going
to interpret this base thing that i'm
doing so i was i was worried about being
judged by them just for doing something
that was different i mean this is
research you should be doing something
that pushes things forward but but in my
mind i was i was worried about how
referees would
believe this
i think there's something else which is
that like
i've like i've taken
i have taken classes in in bays i've
taught a class in bays
you know i i i still
i still like when i have to construct my
priors i always kind of pause and i say
well how informative should it be how
flat should they be
um
and it just you know maybe that's maybe
that's the cringe it's like i just i
sort of like seize up at that point i'm
like i really don't kind of know what to
do at this point and i'm really afraid
of being wrong i mean it's nice that
gelman gave us
gave us an out and said like look you
can be wrong just like put yourself out
there and then learn
um
and then you know there's also you know
back when i learned uh bayes i i learned
it in jags
you know it's it's really the syntax
wasn't great um and
i was just you know we tend to use the
tools that we uh we know a lot and we've
used a lot and you know i hadn't i
hadn't dug into base in five years and
so uh i was worried about was stepping
forward with that
of course there was just like plain
laziness right um
you know why do why do something more
complicated than it needs to be um and
then of course our friend bajan cringe
okay so
i i'm happy to say that all these fears
were unfounded um
like i i i sort of knew this was the
right way to go forward and i i
finally did the dive into all the stuff
that had happened in the
in the uh the stan world
i had to channel inside of myself i knew
that there was like there was like an r
super superhero and i had to channel
that so i just you know i just calmly
meditated on that and i imagined like
pulling
this inner andrew gelman for myself um
and then i just you know i i i dived
into everything and
i didn't mean any of that all the tools
were super easy um you know our standard
was fantastic
um
i think it helped out someone like me
who was working with models uh
that that i hadn't uh specified priors
for before
uh the validation tools are fantastic
tidy base is fantastic
um i just i thought it was going to be
much harder than it was and it wasn't
and i just have to give such uh uh uh
like so much uh thanks for the people
who work on these tools um and uh you
know thanks for making our lives so much
easier um so i encourage everybody who's
thinking about
um going into bayesian methods looking
for this um
okay so let's go back to our our um
let's go back to our case let's look at
how much uh explainable ai impacts
uh
uh whether somebody is going to update
uh their their delay estimate so how
much is this going to affect trust in
machine learning
so we're estimating a poisson model
about how much an absolute value
somebody updated the delay estimate and
we're just going to estimate just a um
just that a coefficient on the treatment
group so whether they're in the
explainable ai treatment
and it looks like uh the
the the coefficient is centered around
1.1 meaning that there's like about a
10 increase in uh how much somebody uh
updates the delay estimate now
you know the average delay update is
only about 2.2 months so this is like
you know this is a sizable impact
i think things get interesting here when
we start to include all the other
moderators that we we thought might have
a role
now notice that like after controlling
for all the others uh individual
characteristics the treatment effects is
mixed which is fine like you know this
is the data that or these are the
posterior that's consistent with the
data and the prior and i'm perfectly
fine with that you know we're not
hunting around for a certain p value
um one thing that was surprising here is
that a higher loan amount means you're
more likely to update your beliefs which
is not something that i you know i think
we thought the direction would be
reversed
something that we didn't expect
that we found that was really striking
is that the most senior members of the
team
are the ones who appear to trust the ai
predictions the least um this was really
strong across all these different
specifications
this this makes sense because
the the person who's in the role the
more senior role might have dived into
more of the project might have more of
their own
career um uh you know brought up in
terms of understanding that particular
uh project
and so they just have they have more to
lose from from trusting a model
um
uh we can also estimate the logistic
model about whether after they viewed
the machine learning tool if they
updated their delay estimate
um
and what we find are you know again kind
of mixed impact of the explainability
treatment which is perfectly fine we do
see that people who self-report as
having more machine learning knowledge
tend to update their delay estimate you
know much greater you know again we see
this negative uh impact of having more
senior roles and these people these
senior roles are like way less likely to
update their delay estimate
um
for self-reported usefulness we do see
this impact of the treatment group so
the explainable ai makes people think
that the
prediction exercise itself is more
useful
um
and then of course higher machine
learning familiarity leads people to uh
believe that the machine learning tool
is more useful as well
um and again this like this manager
closeness effect we we tend to find
um
i think things get really interesting
once we start to look at heterogeneous
treatment effects
um
so we're looking we're basically
interacting this treatment group with
these individual characteristics
and we find these really really strong
effects
about the people who are least likely to
trust ai initially if they happen to be
in the explainable ai treatment group
they're much more likely to update their
belief um
and these these you know point estimates
are really large so the chief of
operations and those who self-report no
familiarity with machine learning
they're they're people who
you know seem to not trust the
the the ai predictions but if they
happen to get this explainable ai
treatment then it seems like they trust
them quite a bit and i i think that's a
really really nice result um it tells us
like you know why are we making this
explainable ai um it seems like we're
making it for the people to build the
models but we're also making it to bring
in people who don't have so much
experience in
in artificial intelligence or machine
learning and help them understand what's
going on and it seems like that has a
very large effect
okay
so to conclude we find that these
explainable ai models actually seem to
increase belief updating
um
they they it seems like they increase
perceived usefulness decrease
understanding of the model
larger loans tend to
are more likely to update their beliefs
and then senior members and those with
lease ml familiarity are least likely to
trust ai but if they they get this
explainable ai uh model
um then they uh greatly increase their
their trust of ai
so
you know to go back
to uh
you know to the to this to this uh our
our our um god that i was trying to i
was trying to channel like who was this
cave crusader was it someone inside me
the whole time no of course not it was
jared lander i was channeling jared
lander and i had to thank him so much
for uh for for showing me the way of
course you know i also have to thank
fiverr artist neural anwar because i'm
not a very good artist but he was able
to turn around this art piece of artwork
in 24 hours
uh you know so thank you and
you know the last thing i would want for
anyone to do here is to
go to this link and download all of
these these wonderful backgrounds i mean
you know include them in your background
um
uh dan could you make an action figure i
mean i i would i would hold this i mean
jared i i've got to say you've been
doing you've been working out in the gym
i mean this is incredible um yeah just
great
okay so that's my talk um if you have
questions or comments you can reach out
to celine or i
thank you so much and uh again thanks
for everyone who's making these
wonderful tools um really appreciate it
thanks john thanks everyone
so speaking of the stan workshop
you